hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play the things in the night I'm
selling the water part I got up and ran
to my room our room ran around my room
for a bit get pumped up I'm ready I'm so
ready ah scared not even a little bit so
still looking for these books know what
that water ok I seriously I'm looking
for the books and I'm not not seeing
them ok seriously I don't have much food
left for you yeah they're eating
is there's another one okay that's to
any oh man there's freaking four of them
I tell you always sound like that right
behind him those rugs go flying whenever
you try to get off
oh man oh man oh man come on
donk ulis
they're really obvious Cecile
this is where the first one was okay I'm
assuming that there's one in each
quadrant of the room that would make
sense you know
front back north/south
I would figure that there would be
another one over here somewhere I'm just
not seeing it oh come on they're far
away it just really sounds like is that
another one oh is that another one that
is totally yes okay I was right there's
one in each quadrant of the room so then
the other one must be here somewhere
oh come on I'll get out of here oh I
don't have any more food ah
I was a mistake looking I'm drifting ah
okay done they're definitely none there
backs of them never make me jump some
terrible ever done there you see any
over there
oh man come on
oh you gotta be kidding me
the freaky frack is it no ah see
something here ah come on
that's all something glowing back there
huh I don't know what it was
plan on it by parts I mean I have these
hahaha I just have to let them go away
oh there was nothing over there but rugs
box they eating eating get in something
here oil oil oil ah
I have found three I I just don't know
where this other one is on the other
side of the room oh I like this
okay I can get this I guess
I got a spot up here Fantasmic just
magical
okay okay they haven't won yet so maybe
this will give me a second to look
around for the one here not there not
see in it just give me some time guys
give me some time
not there not there not there at all I'm
not seeing it
oh come on
come on give me no longer little longer
little longer
let's see it don't see it oh I'm really
looking guys I'm really looking oh I'm
coming up on the other one the other one
I already found that one already found
that one ah better oh god they're close
oh okay there another one here maybe I
don't know one in there impossible to
tell
somebody parked over here over there no
oh I hate this I hate this just let it
kill me
all right take me my vice
cuz they get time I need to find where
this fourth one is because I get time
until I actually touch put my hand on
like the book that's when they spawn so
I just need to find them
I just got to find it okay
so the first one is in that shell I can
see it from here
that's what I'm looking from that time
ago right there it's a nutshell I can
see from there like I can spot it huh
see
okay I got plenty of time I'm just not
gonna hover my hand over until I see it
not they're coming up on the next one
that I already know she's right I'm
assuming they'd all be on the same level
so that they'd all be graphical but you
never know with these things
just coming up on the one that I already
know is here which is up there okay it
could be up there that's the one up
there
down there I'm there if there was
another one I would assume it would be
in this quadrant
oh and I've already really looked at
these
I swear unless there's only three am I
wrong and thinking that there were four
yeah four there's four books this
formosa's freaks
I'm coming up in the next one I already
know is there there it is that's the
other book it's got to be something else
here too
gotta be something along with other
words gotta be gotta be got it don't
dick around with me rug
and here is the first that's them well
how I've looked at every single
bookshelf and I've always seen three I
swear I've seen every single bookshelf
only seen three
and it was I'm just an idiot you all are
pointing out because you saw it before
but I have not still don't holy hell
okay what is the deal with this took the
skull
part of the guys sick game
Oh
oh it's right there I'm such an [ __ ]
I didn't know there was another
all right I got this pull it pull it
pull it pull it please pull it I don't
have time for this
ya know over the next week not in this
section
here jump jump your bastard all right
hurry hurry hurry hurry hurry
coming up next one right here okay and
then the last one I know where it is you
know I don't know I know don't get me
don't give me bro I got it I got it huh
what you gotta be kidding me
I went super mega ultra fast look like a
fastest ever look like come on you're
right where them okay
oh come on how is this even possible ah
I freaking did it as fast never mind
boom
oh I'm so fun seriously
I pulled the canals clicked
there we go God oh man I thought I
thought I was gonna be like that try it
over and over and over again
oh okay now what was the point of that
what was the point of that
what was the point of that well first
let me celebrate my victory all right so
I don't know what the point of that was
we can open the door oh yeah the gate
the gates upstairs that's right oh man
so what was with the whole area with the
sparkly beams
who's that deal is that something that
still needs to come up in the future is
that gone I don't know like utterly
confused Oh way it wasn't here this
wasn't it this wasn't it was uh I was on
the other way I know
oh man I wasn't so much a tough puzzle
as it was I should have realized that
there were other bookshelves
oh right find my eyes why why why you I
do that today I should have realized
that there were others okay that's the
portal and this open this one yeah
toast toast man toast man okay what's up
I don't like this ah
no I have no lantern oil oh you said you
Oh what is this Oh what I fell down I
couldn't take it anymore
that's no good get back up get up get up
get up get up get up
huh she's still there I think so oh oh
okay okay still there
I must have missed this with everything
moving I just saw that one pop up in
front of me okay I think it's gone oh
why did I need to come in here I didn't
need to come in here did I this is just
a freaking trick chair hey buddy
haha good old friend pal well that
didn't give up any light at all Oh
friend oh my friend please save me oh
what's in here oil well sparing oil in
the world I'm not going to waste it
though
I've really literally got a walkthrough
oh I'm all out of time anyway
so whoo all right thank you all so much
for watching and as always I will see
you in the next part
bye bye